Veränderungen für die Hoffnung
über Jahrzehnte hinweg haben Menschen
gewarnt vor den Folgen wenn wir so tun
wenn wir so weitermachen wie bisher
diejenigen die am meisten betroffen sind
von der Klimakrise
Leiden und die Wissenschaft ist hier
deutlich die Kohle muss im Boden bleiben
wir müssen die Zerstörung unseres
Planeten stoppen
wir müssen aufhören
Menschenopfer zu erbringen im Kauf oder
im Gegenzug für
unternehmerischen Profit
die Menschen an der Macht Handeln jedoch
nicht
wie kann es sein dass nichts geschieht
im Jahr
2023 wie kann es sein dass wir immer
noch uns auf einem Weg befinden der ins
nirgends ins Nichts führt wie kann das
sein
wieso müssen Menschen sterben nur weil
ein paar wenige Menschen unglaublich
viel Geld
verdienen möchten
es geht um Profite für ein paar wenige
unglaublich reiche Menschen sie möchten
einfach nur Geld verdienen
alles weiter wir zerstören weiterhin den
Lebensraum und wir unterdrücken und
diskriminieren weiterhin Menschen die
deutsche Regierung schließt Abkommen ab
mit
kohleunternehmen und Energieunternehmen
wie RWE und dies ist eine Schande es
zeigt uns ganz genau wo hier die
Prioritäten liegen die Priorität sind
nicht die Menschen sondern die Profite
wie einmal mehr wie immer
[Applaus]
wenn Regierungen und Konzerne jedoch
scheitern so wie jetzt dann treten wir
Menschen ein wir die wir heute hier sind
so sollte es jedoch nicht sein
aber so ist sie Lage
und dies
ist ein Verrat an den künftigen und
gegenwärtigen Generationen die Tatsache
jedoch dass ihr alle hier seid ist ein
Zeichen der Hoffnung
das ist nur ein ein Teil der großen
Klimabewegung Bewegung weltweit für
Klimagerechtigkeit und Gerechtigkeit
allgemein
was hier in lützelrath passiert bleibt
nicht hier
deutschland ist einer der größten
Klimasünder weltweit und hat somit eine
riesige Verantwortung es muss
Verantwortung übernommen werden und
deshalb sind wir heute hier
passieren ähnliche Dinge auf der ganzen
Welt und wir müssen sicherstellen dass
auch dort so viel Aufmerksamkeit hin
gelangt
wir müssen den klimakampf vernetzen und
solidarisch sein Menschen auf der ganzen
Welt verfolgen was hier gerade passiert
und das ist nur ein weiteres Zeichen wie
sehr wir vernetzt sind
wir werden uns weiterhin solidarisch
zeigen und
weltweit uns einsetzen für
Klimagerechtigkeit die Kolonialisierung
und für
den Kampf gegen Rassismus
[Applaus]
heute zeigt dir eindeutig dass die
Veränderungen nicht von der Regierung
von Konzernen durchgeführt werden von
den sogenannten Entscheidungsträgern
nein
sondern durch Menschen die in
Baumhäusern sitzen die hier auf der
Straße sind
wir kämpfen hier schon seit langem
[Applaus]
danke also
danke euch allen die Kohle ist noch im
Boden wir sind noch hier
lützerath gibt es noch
und solange die Kohle im Boden ist es
dieser Kampf nicht vorbei
wir haben nicht vor aufzugeben
Blitze bleibt
sie
[Applaus]
thank you danke
danke
[Musik]
ja meine Damen und Herren das war der
kurze kompakte Auftritt von Greta
Thunberg 20 Jahre alt schwedische
klimaaktivistin
Mitbegründerin der Organisation Fridays
for future der Bewegung die sich hier an
die Demonstranten in unserer Art
gewendet hat und möglicherweise auch
relativ schnell jetzt nach Schweden
zurückkehren muss denn dort hat die neue
konservativ liberale Regierung in dieser
Woche ein Vorhaben auf dem Weg gebracht
neue Atomkraftwerke zu bauen also viel
zu tun auch an anderer Stelle wir wollen
ein bisschen sprechen über das was
dieser Auftritt hier bedeutet hat an
diesem Tag ich freue mich weiterhin das
Professor
Frank Decker bei uns im Studio ist da
Politikwissenschaftler Uni Bonn ähm
genauso wie lützerat ein Symbol ist sie
haben über diese Bolik von Dingen
gesprochen so ist auch fortunawerk ein
Symbol und eine Ikone dieser
Bewegung inwieweit konnte sie heute der
Sache dienlich sein
ja welcher Sache müsste man dann erstmal
fragen was sie dann am Ende gesagt hat
blitzi bleibt da weiß sie natürlich
genau wie die alle anderen das lützt sie
nicht bleiben wird aber darum geht es
nicht sondern es geht darum in der Tat
mit diesem Symbol das Thema auf der
politischen Agenda zu halten
diesen Protest werden dann andere
Protestmaßnahmen folgen und sie hat eben
gesagt
die Klimapolitik wird nicht von
Regierungen und Unternehmungen gemacht
sondern von uns von den Demonstranten
also von den Bürgern vom Volk und das
ist natürlich
nur die halbe Wahrheit denn die
Klimapolitik muss
umgesetzt werden die Ziele müssen ja
erreicht werden und dazu braucht es eine
ökologische Transformation der
Wirtschaft die natürlich politisch
organisiert und begleitet werden muss wo
sie aber recht hat ist dass diese
Bewegung Druck ausübt insbesondere auf
die Politik schneller voranzugehen bei
dieser Umsetzung dort hat sie einiges
erreicht und sie wird auch in Zukunft
nicht nachlassen denn dieses Thema
bleibt jetzt eine Dauerbaustelle für die
Politik und Frank Decker wir reden
gleich noch mal einen in einem letzten
kurzen Exkurs aber genau das nehme ich
auf diesen Gedanken von Professor Frank
Decker meine Damen und Herren was Klima
Bewegung geschafft hat ist Politik in
ihrem Denken und in ihrem Ansatz ein
wenig zu verändern und die Dinge
gemeinsam zu denken genau das ist ein
Gedanke gewesen den die CDU der
Parteivorstand der Bundesvorstand
zweimal in der Klausur noch einmal
operiert hat wir hatten Friedrich Merz
schon ein bisschen unterbrochen jetzt
wollen wir noch einmal eine kompakte
Version über das neue Denken Wirtschaft
Ökologie aber auch Klimaschutz zusammen
Friedrich Merz
wir haben